[Musique]
bonjour frédéric péchenard bonjour des
dizaines de manifestants qui scandent
suicidez vous à des policiers avant-hier
à paris quelle a été votre réaction
une une incompréhension une tristesse
un agacement un énervement profond c'est
incompréhensible
c'est incompréhensible c'est honteux
c'est scandaleux
gv liger j'ai pas de mot ça me dépasse
bien que je comprends que les gens
veuillent manifester je comprends que
parfois on puisse être confrontés aux
forces de l'ordre qui rappelons le quand
même sont juste là pour faire en sorte
que les choses se passent bien
alors les les insultes les provocations
à ce point là c'est scandaleux et on
peut vraiment se poser la question de
savoir si tout ça est pas quelque chose
de délibéré on voit bien qu'il ya une
espèce de radicalisation d'un certain
nombre de personnes dans ce mouvement d
gilet jaune ce que les services de
renseignement appelle les ultras jaunes
et les black blocks
on voit bien que là ils cherchent
l'affrontement
il cherche la difficulté ils cherchèrent
dérapages lice aussi franchement il faut
rendre hommage aux forces de l'ordre qui
semaine après semaine malgré
l'épuisement malgré les provocations
réussissent à contenir
voilà on a vu toussaint les ce qui se
passe à la télévision en dehors des
suicides est vous qui est absolument
scandaleux surtout quand on connaît la
réalité de la police aujourd'hui ces
gens qui arrivent au contact des
policiers qui les insultent qui les
insultent pendant de très longues
minutes sous les caméras bienveillante
de la télévision et les policiers qui
restent impassibles m'a franchement ils
font leur métier mais ils le font bien
chapeau alors il ya l'un des animateurs
du mouvement d'aidé gilet jaune jérôme
rodriguez qui a clairement condamné ces
propos qui reflètent pas le mouvement de
gilet jaune selon lui mais ils
l'expliquent
il explique cette cesser ses propos ses
appels au suicide par un certain climat
qui règne selon jérôme en des guest
depuis plusieurs semaines ça fait quatre
mois qu'on en prend plein la tronche ça
fait quatre mois qu'on se fait insulter
ça fait quatre mois qu'on nous ait
borgne comme utile qu'on se fait frapper
qu'on est victimes d'arrestations
arbitraires et comme tout être humain je
suis pas psychologue pour un sou
quand un être humain on prend une dans
la tronche de
3 un moment donné il finit par se
rebiffer et elle en distribue lui aussi
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cet
argument turf eric chenais je pense que
c'est une inversion totale de ce qui se
passe dans la réalité une inversion
totale des valeurs c'est à dire que ça
fait effectivement quatre mois que les
gilets jaunes manifeste ce qui en soi ne
pose aucun problème
on est dans une démocratie est un droit
de manifester sauf que moi ce que je
vois depuis quatre mois dupuy 23
semaines c'est pas des manifestants ce
sont des émeutiers
c'est que ce sont des gens qui prennent
possession de la de la rue lors
notamment à paris moi je suis élu
parisien j'habite paris dont je suis ce
qui se passe à paris si vous voulez et
il ya des agressions sur des policiers
près de 2000 policiers ont été blessés
19 policiers encore blessé la semaine
dernière
les voitures sont brûlées quand vous dit
les magasins sont pillés quand vous des
émeutiers fresnel que je vous parlais de
tous les manifestants ou en son nom
alors je parle pas de tous les
manifestants il faut bien mettre des
choses de côté il ya des gens qui
viennent manifester manifester ça veut
dire que on déclare la préfecture ont
dit voilà je suis pas content contre le
président de république
je vais manifester je vais des points à
un point b et je manifeste et là les
forces de l'ordre sont autour pour
protéger la vie des faits station pour
éviter des débordements etc
mais là vous avez un certain nombre de
personnes alors c'est vrai les black
block c'est vrai des ultras journée
cetera qui viennent pas pour manifester
et ça c'est pas depuis depuis ce samedi
c'est depuis le 2e samedi qui viennent
pour casser pour piller cas que dans le
17e arrondissement on a été largement
touchée par exemple la rue de courcelles
où rue de prony ont été détruites
dévasté les gens qui mettent le feu aux
voitures les gens qui cassent des
vitrines des gens qui pillent les
magasins des gens qui attaquent les
forces de l'ordre spontanément par le
plaisir et bien ce sont des émeutiers se
sont des délinquants et nous avons
doivent donc être traités comme tels
vous pensez qu'on va retrouver
identifier les personnes qu'on a vu sur
cette vidéo on en a les moyens
oui bien sûr bien sûr la police
française est bien fait on les
retrouvera alors après comme on retrouve
d'ailleurs une partie des casseurs et
une partie des pilleurs on le fait on le
fait dans le temps le fait avec le
rythme judiciaire de l'enquète mais oui
on va les retrouver bien sûr les
services de renseignement et ça je peux
juste dire sont là pour ça pose deux
problèmes que même une raclée quelque
chose il faut quand même mettre sur la
table il ya eu neuf mille personnes à
peu près qui ont été arrêtées depuis le
début des événements quand je dis
arrêtez s'il veut dire placé en garde à
vue
je parle pas des contrôles je pars à des
contrôles d'identité et des fouilles des
gens placés en garde à vue
quand vous êtes placé en garde à vue
c'est que la police soupçonne d'avoir
commis un délit ou un crime donc voyez à
9000 personnes qui ont été interpellées
par la police gardait entendu parce
qu'ils étaient soupçonnés d'avoir commis
un délit ou un crime
sur ces neuf mille personnes la quasi
totalité sont dehors aujourd'hui 5 %
seulement sont sur mandat de dépôt on
cueillait au début une certaine
mansuétude ans le comprend au bout de 23
semaines avec les semaines qui les des
scènes qui se répètent constamment si
insupportable prenons encore mon avis il
ya deux explications à saint frédéric
péchenard soit une forme pour reprendre
votre propos de mansuétude de la justice
soit une absence de preuve alors il ya
aussi une troisième solution parce que
les d'absence de preuves c'est normal
que jean soit pas condamné la mansuétude
de la justice ça ne me regarde pas ça ne
regarde personne puisque les magistrats
sont indépendants moi je pense que c'est
plutôt une question d' instructions
données terre le garde des sceaux doit
donner des instructions extrêmement
ferme au parquet pour systématiquement
poursuivre et systématiquement requérir
des peines importantes
regardez par exemple une dernière
hypothèse sur des pièces narcy aussi que
la police finalement interpelle trop
aimé trop de gens en garde à vue tiens
je ne crois pas et pas les bons
franchement oui bien sûr c'est ce qu'on
dit toujours j'en sais rien j'ai j'y
suis pas c'est pas moi qu'il fallait
pour ses 9 5% seulement à l'arrivée
oui bah c'est pas beaucoup les c'est de
la faute de la justice jeu d instruction
je ne dis pas que c'est la faute je
faisais moi j'aime pas beaucoup dire
c'est facile de dire c'est la faute de
l'autre en permanence je fais pas partie
des policiers qui disait les policiers
arrêtent les magistrats relâche c'est
pas du tout le ca les policiers arrêtent
les magistrats condamnent et après la
peine des peines ne sont pas exécutés ou
mal exécutée je prends un exemple le
boxeur qui a frappé notamment frappé un
gendarme au sol il est condamné à un an
de prison ferme
voilà une condamnation qui paraît qui
paraît mesuré qui paraît normal pas tout
vous avez frappé deux policiers
ça mérite pas perpétuité mais ça mérite
pas non plus une contravention est bien
le problème c'est l'exécution de cette
peine puisqu'il a fait recette peine en
semi liberté ça veut dire qu'il va être
dehors la journée ça signifie que
potentiellement j'imagine qu'il l'a pas
fait mais potentiellement ils pourraient
être une manifestation d gilet jaune et
et recommencer des actes de violence ça
ça s'appelle les aménagements de peine
vous connaissez ça et bien
pour diriger la police pendant quelques
années je n'y suis pas favorable à ce
point là je publie que pour les gilet
jaune pour tous évidemment on veut pas
que voler gilet jaune
on a un vrai sujet en france qui
l'exécution de la peine et d'ailleurs
madame belloubet et on a un autre sujet
massa vettel a récidivé on sait que
l'adhésion plutôt un facteur de réussite
pas du tout absolument pas la madame
belloubet l'a dit les peines inférieures
à six mois de prison ne seront plus
exécutées c'est un petit peu l'idée une
peine courte n'est pas une bonne peine
le miz intérieure a dit que la prison
pouvait être criminogènes bon attendez
puis un sujet qui est la surpopulation
curseur alors ça ça arrive c'est le seul
vrai sujet ça sur un peu surpopulation
carcérale
nous n'avons pas s'il places de prison
en france voilà concrètement nous avons
soixante mille places de prison il faut
savoir par exemple que nos amis anglais
en ont 96000 nos amis espagnols qui sont
pourtant moins nombreux que nous on n'en
77000 une démocratie comme la france
devrait avoir 80000 places de prison
parce qu'on ne peut pas faire de
politique pénale en fonction des places
de prison
on fait une politique pénale en fonction
des condamnations prononcées par les
tribunaux parce que finalement qu'est-ce
qui se passe
les tribunaux prononcent des
condamnations qui ne sont pas appliquées
c'est ça qui est scandaleux 28 policiers
se sont donné la mort depuis le début de
l'année la police elle est mise en
première ligne depuis maintenant plus de
cinq mois avec ce mouvement des gilets
jaunes dans quel état à vos yeux est
aujourd'hui la police nationale frédéric
péchenard escalettes au bordeaux au bord
de craquer alors bord le crack et
j'espère bien sûr que non elle est dans
une situation délicate et ce depuis
plusieurs années on peut considérer que
c'est ça jamais été facile d'être
policier les policiers ont toujours été
en première ligne c'est normal c'est de
le dernier rempart l'ultime rempart de
démocratie et de et de la république
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'il faut
faire attention à notre police parce que
c'est le dernier rempart de la
démocratie
voilà donc ça c'est très important de
faire attention notre police bonjour le
gouverement fait assez attention je ne
sais quelle précision
c'est que à chaque fois qu'il ya une
enquête d'opinion sur la police est bien
celle ci est extrêmement favorable
la dernière enquête d'opinion c'est je
crois l'ifop en janvier 2010 9 75% des
français apprécient leur police y ont
confiance dans la police voilà donc les
faut que les policiers qu'ils
m'entendent ce matin ils le savent mais
sache que
l'immense majorité des français sont
derrière eux voilà ça c'est la première
chose
la seconde c'est qu'on a un nombre de
suicides tout à fait anormal cette année
naturellement ça être pratiquement si on
continue sur cette lancée ça sera deux
fois plus que d'habitude entre
guillemets parce que toujours eu quand
même d'aider à sa nombre de suicides
dans la police mais cette vague de
suicides elle a augmenté depuis déjà
2015 d'un convoi qu' il ya eu les
attentats avec une pression très forte
sur le travail de la police
il ya maintenant les gilet jaune depuis
20 ans 23 semaines avec une pression
très forte sur la police et comme
toujours dans les dents dans les
affaires de suicides chez des sujets que
j'ai suivi de très près quand j'étais
directeur général de la police
vous avez des causes multifactorielles
c'est à dire que c'est rare que
quelqu'un se suicide pour une seule
cause c'est souvent plusieurs
difficultés
réunis mais une fois que j'ai dit ça
peut-être aussi que vos les problèmes
professionnels que vous avez peuvent se
ressentir sur votre couple et vice versa
des policiers jean trois week-ends
d'affilée à paris ça veut dire qu'ils ne
sont pas chez eux
ça veut dire qu'ils rentrent le soir
épuisé parfois couverts d'excréments
blessés donc tout ça crée des
difficultés aussi dans le couple est ce
qu'on est capable de continuer à assurer
la sécurité des manifestants dans les
semaines qui viennent il ya une nouvelle
même mobilisation prévue samedi prochain
et le 1er mai qui arrive également avec
des manifestations syndicales mais
également des black blocs l'ultra gauche
qui ont prévu de se retrouver est ce que
vous dites attention warning les
manifestations du 1er mai cette année ne
pourront pas se dérouler comme prévu
alors le mec fait sur du premier mais je
pense qu'il faudra que se débrouille
comme prévu le 1er mai c'est quelque
chose qui est très symbolique très
important mais pas question de rogner
sur les libertés syndicales du 1er mai
c'est un rendez-vous qui absolument
incontournable par contre je pense qu'il
faut faire en sorte au maximum
d'économiser des forces
vous savez ces clients façon économe à g
c'est pas tellement nouveau 1
j'étais opposé à la création de la fan
zone pour l'euro 2016 à paris à partir
de 2015 et forces de l'ordre ont été
très très sollicités bon on était
d'ailleurs en état d'urgence et y avait
une fan zones qui étaient sous la tour
eiffel est évidemment pour sécuriser la
fan zone
il a fallu mettre énormément de forces
mobiles autour forceville que avec
lequel je je parlais je discutais
j'étais les rencontrer et il y à des crs
qui me disaient nous on a fini à 4
heures du matin en banlieue parisienne
et à 9 heures on est là se met alors sur
quoi on peut faire des économies lost
aujourd'hui concrètement moi j'avais
demandé à l'époque ça avait été refusé
par madame hidalgo mais j'ai demandé à
l'époque que la fan zone ne soit pas à
cet endroit là mais soit au stade
charléty parce que un stade c'est fermé
c'est beaucoup plus facile à contrôler
et au lieu de mettre neuf compagnies de
crs
on aurait pu en mettre qu'une seule bon
je crois qu'il ya des choix à faire qui
demande un petit peu de 2,2 de courage
parce que là on va pas faire manifester
les gens 1er mai dans un stade bien sûr
que non mais par exemple ce week end à
le dernier week-end
il ya eu sur l'ensemble de la france
trente mille manifestants aient eu
soixante mille policiers
alors je je sais bien que quand on est
mise intérieure et que la situation est
aussi difficile
c'est pas simple de faire des choix mais
faisons bien attention de pas avoir
ceinture et bretelles et utiliser des
forces de l'ordre à bonne escient
franchement soixante mille policiers
pour trente mille manifestants
même si sur ces trente mille
manifestants il y avait beaucoup de
d'émeutiers qui venaient en et coudre
peut-être se permettre aux policiers ce
week-end en france nos vidéos que je
crois pas que c'est ce que vous dites
non j'ai pas dis ça je dis pas dire il
ya trente mille manifestants soutiennent
il faut s'interroger sur l'adéquation
leur tour mais plus de manifestants soit
on met moins de policiers parce que
l'alliance est mal compris là vous avez
très bien compris mais je ne veux pas
caricaturer ma position avait trop
policiers passent et policiers je crois
que d'une façon générale il faut essayer
d'équilibrer les missions savez il faut
il faut prioriser les missions et s'il
devait y avoir pas tout c'est pas à moi
d'en décider c'est au préfet de police
au ministère intérieur s'il devait y
avoir 6 et 6 ont estimé par s'ils ont
des informations que je n'ai pas que
devait y avoir 60 mille policiers
signifie qu'il faut il faut probablement
bas
faire en sorte d'autres missions soient
moins prioritaires renault des légumes
un changement de stratégie aussi ce
week-end phonique resterait ce que vous
dites yéyé soixante mille policiers
finalement il ya eu plutôt moins de
dégâts et moins de violence que ce qui
était redouté au préalable quelques
jours avant il ya eu plus de 20000
contrôles d'identité préventifs c'est ça
la solution il faut contrôler tout le
monde avant alors la solution
vous savez vous m'aviez invité il ya
quelques semaines sur ce plateau et
j'avais dit modestement ce que je pense
qu'il fallait faire alors je vois que
c'est ce qui a été suivie finalement
qu'il fallait rappelez vous je vous ai
décrit à les interdire certaines
manifestations
voilà celle qui dont on pensait qu'elle
allait dégénérer donc des rassemblements
interdits parce que quand ils sont
interdits ça permet justement de faire
des contrôles d'identité ça a été fait
et je pensais aussi qu'il fallait
arrêter d'avoir une vision statique des
choses
la vision statique de la police c'est à
dire que c'est pour les manifestations
classiques
la police a par besoin d' interpeller
bohème association classique a pas
besoin de bouger mais là quand vous avez
faire des gens qui sont je le répète une
fois de plus non pas des manifestants
mais des émeutiers
il faut que la police soit dynamique
c'est à peu près ce qu'on a vu ce week
end et c'est tant mieux frédéric
péchenard on est presque une semaine
après l incendie à notre dame on sait qu
emmanuel macron à repousser
l'intervention l allocution qu'il devait
faire face aux français en début de
semaine dernière sa conférence de presse
ce sera jeudi
est ce que vous trouvez que dans cette
affaire il a adopté le bon ton depuis l'
incendie
vous avez d'abord vous pouvez pas
reprocher à un homme politique de faire
la politique
bon donc évidemment il avait la
politique bien sûr comme comme le fond
audience au mauvais sens du terme au bon
sens du terme
alors évidemment et il espère en avoir à
bénéfice personnel politique ce que je
comprends bon après sur le fond il était
là au moment où ça s'est passé il a dit
des choses qui me paraissent qui me
paraissaient convenable
et puis il faut qu'on reconstruise cette
cathédrale le député le républicain eric
ciotti lui dénonce une récupération
politicienne indigne de la part d'
emmanuel macron c'est ce que je dis mais
de metz à sa façon différente à vie mais
non c'est aussi une récupération de
cette catastrophe par le colonel ri mais
je laisse la politique vous l'avait dit
et dire c'est une récupération politique
et les sens et de la politique pour moi
c'est les petits degrés dans la nuit
c'est normal de faire de la politique
quand vous êtes peu d'ordre public alors
voici ce que dit maintenant vote
tête de liste aux européennes françois
xavier bellamy je regrette que le
président de la république dans son
allocution depuis l'elysée comme
christophe castaner ministre de
l'intérieur ministre des cultes
hier à paris mais pas eu un mot pour
parler aux chrétiens aux catholiques au
coeur de ce moment si singulier pour eux
emmanuel macron aurait dû s'adresser
plus particulièrement aux catholiques
oui en l'occurrence en l'occurrence oui
oui oui parce que non alors notre dame
c'est c'est le symbole de paris
c'est le symbole du tourisme aussi vous
axez le le monument qui est le plus
visité en france et le père en europe
il n'en demeure pas moins que c'est une
cathédrale et que c'est unsa des draps
ou quatre catholiques
on voit bien d'ailleurs que la
communauté catholique et patrick amand
frappé par ça et puis par d'autres
choses les attentats au sri lanka par
exemple ma montre que c'est dans
certains pays du monde la communauté
catholique minoritaire est quand même
une cible toujours important de voir
prioritaire donc je crois que c'est une
communauté qu'il faut soutenir et qu'il
faut faire un petit peu attention et
c'est vrai que un mot de compassion
spécifique n'aurait pas été malvenu
c'est ce qu'a fait le problème le point
de vue que le premier soir où soir
d'avril deux incendies il aurait dû le
renouveler oui aujourd'hui vous
considérez vous évoquiez les attentats
au sri lanka que la communauté
catholique et les chrétiens en général
sont particulièrement ciblés a bien sûr
bien sûr on l'a vu dès on l'a vu partout
dans les pays du moyen-orient avec des
communautés qui ont de plus en plus de
mal à affirmer
leur identité a élections soumis à des
persécutions permanente
mais même même en france et
je rappelle que 1 des terroristes qui a
été arrêtées préventivement après avoir
abattu une femme de avait comme projet
d'attaqué l'église de villejuif
reste qu'à votre connaissance monsieur
péchenard votre party les républicains à
participer au don pour la cathédrale
notre dame de paris
alors à l'heure où je vous parle je n'en
sais absolument rien ou est ce qu'il
faut le faire
déclaration laurent wauquiez c'est un
choix qui doit être un choix individuel
que moi je vais faire par exemple voilà
mais c'est un choix qui est d'un choix
individuel je pense pas que le parti a
donné doit pas donner l'exemple aux je
crois pas non enfin je sais pas ce que
va faire le party là dessus ni l'un ni
l'autre ne me choquent si vous n'avez
pas tout si le parti voulait apporter
une contribution pourquoi pas mais ça ne
me paraît pas être par essence le rôle
d'un parti politique
emmanuel macron a donc repoussé son
allocution c'est qui s'exprimera jeudi à
l'occasion d'une conférence de presse
est là qu'il développera ses ses
propositions de sortie du grand débat il
ya une piste qui est avancé par le
gouvernement et par d'élise et qui est
celle d'inciter les français à
travailler davantage pour financer les
baisses d'impôts est ce que vous validez
ce jugement est ensuite quelle mesure il
ya trois possibilités soit remettre en
cause des 35 heures soit repoussé l'âge
légal du départ en retraite soit une
deuxième journée de solidarité à
l'instar du lundi de pentecôte rien que
ce nord d'abord je pense que c'est
jamais une bonne idée de parler des
choses avant qu'elles arrivent tard pour
dire les choses clairement
j'attendrai mois jeudi soir que le
président macron se soit exprimé pour
avoir une idée
alors bon il ya des fuites visiblement
dans ce qui devait être dit moi sommes
ça me ça me convient pas si vous voulez
de parler sur des choses qui sont pas
qu'ils sont pas acté voilà donc si vous
voulez le républicain reste à mieux
répondre à ces questions vous voir vous
murray
je vous parlais des retraites parce que
finalement c'est une des unes des pistes
moi je crois que ce qui est extrêmement
important dans notre pays c'est de
maintenir les retraites dire que les
retraités gardent leur pouvoir d'achat
voilà quand vous êtes à la retraite
quand vous êtes quand vous êtes âgés
quand vous pouvez plus travailler parce
que parce que vous êtes âgé parce que
vous êtes fatigués par la vie parce que
vous êtes malade et bien vous devez
avoir
on peut pas s'attaquer à ces gens là
voilà vous devez avoir une certitude et
est d'ailleurs ce qui est un petit peu
inquiétant je trouve en ce moment et qui
participe d'ailleurs de l'inquiétude
générale c'est l'ambiance anxiogène
quand vous lancer en l'air quinze
propositions de réforme en permanence et
bien les gens sont inquiets ou ont parlé
des difficultés dans la police tout à
l'heure avec les suicides
il ya une intersyndicale sur les
suicides y en a une autre sur les
retraites les policiers sont inquiets
parce qu'ils ont un régime de retraite
depuis toujours et ils ne savent pas à
quelle sauce ils vont être mangés
pour moi ce qui me paraît absolument
essentiel c'est d'aller dans la
prolongation de ce qu'a fait nicolas
sarkozy
la seule réforme des retraites sérieuse
qui a été fait c'est celle de 2010 on
est passé de 60 à 62 ans
bien ça ne suffit à l'évidence pas on
voit bien que tous nos voisins européens
c'est vrai des allemands c'est vrai des
anglais c'est vrai des italiens c'est
vrai des espagnols partent entre 65 et
66 ans c'est évidemment la piste qu'il
faut suivre parce que c'est la piste qui
permettra de maintenir les retraites
idée tout à fait anormal que des gens
qui à 90 ans aujourd'hui voient leur
retraite baissé voilà donc il faut
impérativement confirmer les retraites
que les retraités que nos que nos
anciens que nos aînés soient absolument
certain de conserver leur pouvoir
d'achat
et puis s'il faut que les actifs
travaillent un peu plus
moi j'ai 62 ans je me vois pas en train
de prendre ma retraite je ne suis pas
malade quelqu'un qui est malade qui est
un métier particulièrement dur j'ai été
policier pendant 30 ans je pense que je
peux continuer à travailler
par contre nous nos aînés ils doivent
pouvoir bénéficier des retraites voilà
donc louis une des pistes oui c'est sans
aucun doute d'allonger le
ce que 65 ou 67 ans et plus plus en tout
cas que cette espèce de réformes qu'on
nous promet des retraites et qui
finalement depuis deux ans tourne en
rond et tourne en boucle et inquiète
tout le monde
voilà sept la réforme qui est préparé
par monsieur delevoye elle est anxiogène
parce qu'en fait on ne sait pas à quoi
elle va aboutir
et ça fait partie notamment sa du
malaise des policiers une deuxième
journée de solidarité travail et ça
aussi c'est anxiogène ou pas c'est pas
anxiogène mais on le disait dans votre
reportage ça suffira évidemment pas donc
essayons de faire de prendre des mesures
que ceux des mesures courageuses des
mesures sérieuses et qui vont suffire
voilà il est très important d'avoir un
gym de retraite qui soient pérennes
c'est une évidence de chacun qui a passé
sa vie à travailler doit avoir droit
dans notre pays une retraite
il faut faire en sorte que ce soit
pérenne et ben on sait très bien il faut
poursuivre progressivement bien sûr faut
faire les choses meilleures progressive
la réforme nicolas sarkozy 2010 et sur
la troisième piste envisagée est que
rappeler renaud dillies à quelques
instants et quand est-ce qu'ils aient
encore des voix dans votre parti chez
les républicains pour dire il faut
revenir sur les 35 heures ou est ce que
c'est un débat du passé c'est un débat
qui est qu un débat intéressant avec une
difficulté c'est que
moi je suis très favorable aux heures
supplémentaires défiscalisées
c'est quelque chose qui a fonctionné qui
fonctionne bien mais évidemment pour
qu'ils eurent supplémentaires il faut
qu'il y ait une limite de travail
donc moi les 35 heures avec la
possibilité de faire des heures
supplémentaires défiscalisées
ça c'est c'est travailler plus pour
gagner plus et c'est quelque chose que
je crois que les gens peuvent comprendre
et peuvent espérer
moi je pense que c'est très important de
pouvoir avoir le paiement des heures
supplémentaires
le revenons si vous voulez bien une
seconde est la police un des problèmes
de la police était heures
supplémentaires ne sont pas payées
à part les crs dire que tous les
policiers qui sont sur le terrain
eh bien ils ont des quand ils viennent
travailler un samedi ils ont des jours
de vacances
ce qui fait que les policiers ont en
moyenne je prends 3 400 jours de
vacances ils ne peuvent jamais prendre
et bien déjà si on payait les heures
supplémentaires et qu'elles soient pas
fiscalisés
je pense que psychologiquement ça
changera un peu les journaux délictueux
d'actionnaires les élections européennes
cédant 1 pen à moi c'est le 26 mai vous
êtes candidat sur la liste conduite par
françois xavier lamy le principal enjeu
en france de ces élections c'est quoi
c'est un duel entre les républicains et
le rationnement nationale non le
principal enjeu
s'ils n'entrent pas dans l'autre la
république en marche et donc sont le
principal enjeu c'est l'europe
évidemment les gens qui viennent voter
ils voient pas forcément des choses
comme ça mais c'est l'europe
concrètement quelle europe on veut moi
je veux une europe qui protège la france
ce qui m'intéresse c'est tout cela comme
la république en marche et le discours
de deux millions de macs rompt avec une
grande une grande grande différence je
suis opposé à l'élargissement
je suis opposé à l'entrée d'autres pays
dans l'espace schengen parce que
l'espace schengen fait partie des choses
qui ne fonctionnent pas et puis dans le
programme que j'ai lu l'idée c'est quand
même de d'avoir encore plus de
technocratie par exemple la création
d'une agence de protection la démocratie
qui permettrait de lutter contre les
cyberattaques et c'est alors j'ai une
bonne nouvelle pour madame l'oiseau
cette agence elle existe ça s'appelle
europol celle agences de police
européenne qui a été créée en 1995
une des spécialités et la cyber sécurité
donc cette sage et faut pas créer des
nouvelles choses
il faut renforcer ce qui existe déjà
j'en profite d'ailleurs puisqu'on parle
de 2,6 très joli mais c'est une vraie
bien très rapidement très rapidement
pour dire que la siq l'europe nous a
apporté énormément de sécurité c'est
vrai avec le mandat d'arrêt européen
c'est vrai avec europol c'est vrai avec
les équipes comme une banquette et que
leur assemblée nationale a voté
systématiquement contre tout ça c'est
d'ailleurs assez curieux imaginez que
vous êtes contre l'immigration et que
vous votez et que vous votez contre la
création d'un corps de gardes frontières
parce que si on veut faire en sorte que
nos frontières soient moins étanche il
faut des gardes frontières sociales mot
de la fin merci beaucoup frais derrière
ces jeunes armés